[Music]  [Music]  say what i want 24 7 365.  i know it's a lie  i don't got time to mess around  oh about that hustle am i right  this is gonna be the best year ever  nothing's gonna get in my way  breakfast is ready  [Music]  is everything okay  i'm a gross red monster  [Applause]  oh look at me stay back this happened  already  what did you say  [Music]  our ancestors had a mystical connection  with red pandas are you kidding me this  little quirk runs in our family  [Music]  you're so cute sick i've always wanted a  tail i'm a freak we love you mae you're  our girl  whoa you're you  any strong emotion  will release the panda abby hit me  [Music]  oh  do you know how dangerous this is you'll  get ripped up into a frenzy and panda  all over  [Music]  my whole life i've been perfect little  meimei  but maybe i like this new me  mama's girls  [Music]  so  [Music]